so you referenced before that you were
in tahrir square what it made me think
was that there was a point not that long
ago and you might not have been part of
this chorus but there was a sense that
hey social media is going to make
uh democracy flourish all over the place
because it's very hard to maintain a
repressive
regime when everyone can have access to
things and organize and then people came
together
uh in the arab spring and toppled
various governments and were like wow
like democracy is going to bloom and
then that naivete essentially went up
like uh
pop-up spoke like in the weeks and
months that followed where in many ways
uh authoritarianism benefited somehow a
lot of the technology-enabled dynamics
did not improve things did you see that
coming like were you someone who was
like hey you know this entire facile
notion that more internet equals more
democracy is not going to work out like
people are hoping i i called [ __ ] on
that from the start um and the reason
why is because there was a narrative
that i consider neocolonial which is
that our tools liberate you right and i
knew fully well and we know fully well
that you know obviously this is great as
a sort of branding campaign for silicon
valley but we knew even at that time
that that you know various types of
quote-unquote personalization algorithms
were sending us into echo chambers and
you know these kinds of these kinds of
terms were known at the time and some of
my colleagues like eli parizer had done
work on that subject so i the reason i
went out there was i was super
interested a in that narrative and b
trying to actually not debunk it but try
to understand in a real way what
contribution of any are these technology
platforms having
in this massive social movement in this
revolution and and what i quickly
realized it was it wasn't that it's not
technologies that contribute to social
change it's what people do with them
that contributes to social change so and
in tahrir at that time in egypt at that
time
less about five percent or less like
robust internet connectivity one percent
or so of social media connectivity those
that were connected to those networks
were more demographically homogeneous
upper middle class
generally liberal
more educated it turned out also the
iquan or the muslim brotherhood also had
robust connectivity and were really the
only organized form of resistance to the
hegemony of the state um and then there
was a very robust labor movement so what
i did is i pivoted around i interviewed
a lot of pretty radical islamists iguan
people i can kind of blend in and out of
things pretty easily um people super
leftist this and that and i tried to
look at what were their technological
practices and here's what i found out
people were realizing they could use
social media to influence journalism
they could influence journalists by
basically posting particular kinds of
content on platforms and getting that
content not just globalized in terms of
having people like see what's going on
around the world but also influence
people within their own country
journalists in their own country are
looking at what these people are posting
on social media and remediating it or
what we call a media ecology
broadcasting it back onto satellite tv
because that's what everybody had at
that time and that was true in a lot of
the middle east and in india where i'm
my family's from that that's a fantastic
feedback loop that they discovered
they're like hey you know what we can
get we can get media coverage exactly we
can hustle this so i was interviewing
people like iman mohaldin you might know
him because he's now a msnbc anchor but
he was like the man al-jazeera english
out there and i was looking at what what
iman was sourcing on twitter who he was
following on twitter and he was he was
strategically following certain kinds of
activists who were putting stuff out and
here's the other cool thing that i saw
people were pulling things off of on
online media like platforms like youtube
and projecting it in public spaces i saw
that all around the country so that had
another kind of circulation of online
offline and the reason why that was
important was that could actually bring
people together to look at some of the
documentation of what was going on some
of which was manipulated content by the
way very propagandist and people would
look at these things and they would just
rile them up so of course blind
technological connectivity in a sense
can dissent disincentivize collective
action but certain forms of
technological connectivity combined with
the use that the brilliance of activists
who understand their own country their
own limitations their own constraints uh
can make a huge change and so that was
really interesting to look at because
occupy happened right after that and i
was also studying occupy afterward yeah
you were right right there at the crux
of history it's wild around the same
time there was a similar naive belief
that now we have seen fail
which is that the internet was going to
connect us all to the sum total of human
knowledge and thus make everyone smarter
more enlightened there'd be new works of
genius because you'd be able to access
everything at your fingertips
fast forward a number of years and it
feels like if anything we've gotten
baser
dumber
more misinformed
more angry and inflamed is this also
something that you kind of saw coming
i was with my friend tristan harris a
couple weeks ago and he called it the
race down the brain stem
because that's the way a lot of these
social media platforms uh operate uh was
this something that you were concerned
about i've heard tristan talk about that
and i've talked to him about that as
well um
yeah it is because of two major reasons
well first of all on the kind of
democratic global level uh we never
really had that global village because
not everyone from the globe was
participating equally not just with
access but also in in content that was
being put out you know wikipedia at a
certain point of time and i love
wikipedia 95
of its uh editors and primary authors
were male and and from the western world
north america canada europe and so on so
that speaks to how even an amazing uh
you know kind of uh pl to technology
like wikipedia
is actually highly asymmetric in terms
of who drives its content but i really
what we really saw was when this whole
personalization thing came up right so
the way google functioned is it used an
algorithm which we call pagerank which
basically said if we're going to rank a
bunch of andrew yangs with one another
we're going to pick the andrew yang that
has the most backlinks linked to it so
it was based on domain based knowledge
what the the the epistemological claim
was
information that's most credible is most
socially validated or socially linked to
so if you notice none of that involves
spying on people right none of that
involved what but but then what happened
is personalization became more about
googling us or socializing us on
facebook right like are we googling or
being googled are we socializing or
being socialized are we using technology
or being used right there's a sort of
dyadic relationship that is unexpressed
and under discussed still to this day so
when they started doing this
personalization stuff what happened is
we became googled and we became googled
not based on sort of a sort of
some sort of neutral notion of relevance
but based on what would grab our
attention and the way that works which i
think is really interesting is it's all
based on correlation so you know if you
andrew yang have looked at you know a
million web pages and i have all this
data about your engagement on those
different web pages which we call
documents in the information sciences
and then i have very similar profile to
you it will recommend content to me
based on correlation mapping it doesn't
actually know what content is
inflammatory or sensational because
we've never really done good ai work yet
to that extent i believe in text mining
so i'm being nerdy here but you know
please no dig in so um so it can't tell
whether it's inflammatory but it can
tell what i'm going to like is that
what is a
to activate and maximize my attention
and we know
through and through and tristan talks
about this that what maximizes that
dopamine release and that cortisol
release
is outrageous content we like to you
know we don't like to get outraged but
when we see the former but we do
we don't like to be outraged but we kind
of do kind of do in this country
and the other really interesting point
that i just want to make you know again
slightly philosophical bent is what's
being fed to us online which is you know
in our present world and which will
likely shape our future in many ways is
all based on the past
i think that's really important to point
out right that our lives are being
directed digitally based on past data
of which we know nothing about we don't
know what data is collected about us by
whom how it's being monetized none of it
but imagine right andrew if your past is
like over determining of who you become
right to me that's a violation of
humanism itself so what you're
describing is why when you google
something and i google something we can
get different results even if we're
demographically very similar even if
we're politically very similar it's no
longer about that it's about the data
body that's the term we use in
engineering we call it a data body which
is sort of like it's a triangulation of
all these different kinds of data points
including data that might not even be
gathered again by me on my phone or me
intentionally it might be data gathered
about me when i'm walking right down the
street and i see that amazon vehicle
right out there because those all have
surveillance cameras external
surveillance cameras yeah they can get
us in the real world too every once in a
while or we'll do something that says
hey
um i i used apple pay
um at this storefront so it's like oh i
know he was there i know that there's
like uh you know a buying pattern that
starts developing
[Music]
you